so Gary you see so much of the Hollywood
fast track is about relationships very
true
Ella is a tough place to read people a
lot of people with hidden agendas how do
you know what it's okay to trust someone
how do they know it's okay to trust us
and you talked about the rule of three
but sometimes you're just in a casual
setting what type of sort of caution or
due diligence should someone do when
forming a partnership a relationship
with someone that they don't really know
that well being they've you know
international social media a few times
the well the the the the good and the
bad there are a lot of people who
profess to know more or be a better
connected or have more seniority than
they you know then they really do but we
have Google we have our ways of
researching people in if you can't find
them online
it's a concerning thing right so you
just look them up and and if you listen
carefully and ask the right questions
and I believe asking the right questions
is the key to you know the kingdom
they'll reveal to you who who they claim
to know or have a rapport with and what
they've done and haven't done and so you
can check those things out that's number
one but the flipside of the coin is the
old adage I think was Charlie tremendous
Jones I forget who said we are the
average of the five people that were
closest to in life so the question is
always how do we continually up our game
SQL evade our relationships and and
that's about targeting people that we
want to be an association with that we
want to have rapport with and so yes
it's okay to be on networking casually
socially and going to events and you
know seminars and all that sort of thing
but never in in in in lieu of that very
intentional kind of network
which says I'm gonna target the people
in each of these categories
representatives agents managers lawyers
producers casting directors editors
cinema time by the way everybody goes
after the same people producers and
agents right well what about everybody
else
the cinematographer sits in the center
of the action on the set that produces
the director the stars all bounded this
person during photography is great he or
she has great relationships and they're
sitting at home like the college
professor waiting for the students who
show up and no one shows up Wow
what if I want my script read by an
award-winning cinematographer what is it
do they have relationships that can read
and my benefit do they know the actors
that I want to get in touch with do they
know some do they have representation of
course they do could their agency help
me they're not used to being asked as
much as producers nation so I say play
belly to human billiards and go to the
people who released harassed but could
be really helpful and maybe did the
perfect cinematographer for your come on
no it's not a big commitment to make so
there's a lot of ways but I say you know
be careful be cautious be smart use
Google know if someone is legit but at
the same time really spend most of your
energy targeting who you really do want
to know
you